a lot of law we're building a lot more
just through the normal budget but we
just came out contract that when it's
all completed out it'll be 115 miles
that's a lot we're talking about 500 to
550 miles and this will be just as what
contract is 115 I'm going there I assume
you're coming with me hon probably the
end of January we have a problem with
the Democrats because Nancy Pelosi is
going to Shutts nutjob and Chuck wants
to have this done I really believe that
he wants to have his done but she's to
only do the shots and she's following
him because she wants to vote so trying
to get the details of that contract on
the border wall the president talking
about that and border security while
traveling to see troops overseas
tweeting out have the Democrats finally
realized that we desperately need border
security and a wall on the southern
border need to stop drugs human
trafficking gang members and criminals
from coming into our country do the Dems
realize that most of the people not
getting paid are Democrats also tweeting
out there is right now a full-scale
manhunt going on in California for an
illegal immigrant accused of shooting
and killing a police officer during a
traffic stop time to get tough on border
security and build the wall that is in
fact true there is a manhunt underway
sheriff's deputies say the suspect was
seen on camera security footage buying
beer at a convenience store they believe
he is in fact an illegal immigrant and
he shot and killed an officer officer
Singh Wednesday after being pulled over
in a gray pickup truck that is all the
backdrop to which this partial
government shutdown continues let's
bring in our panel Jason Riley Wall
Street Journal columnist and senior
fellow at the Manhattan Institute Molly
Hemingway senior editor at the
Federalist and Amy Walter national
editor for the cook Political Report
Jason your thoughts on the context here
on the big picture of all of this well
the Democrats seem to be pushing for
Trump to abandon any wall funding which
i think is very unrealistic a bread I
think the smarter move would be for
Democrats to offer some funding in
return for something they want such as
amnesty for the dreamers who are very
popular with people from from both
parties
you know in the short run I don't think
that this that this shutdown is really
hurting the president his supporters
want it he campaigned on it they want
him to to fulfill a campaign promise and
I think Trump has become convinced that
if he doesn't continue to push for this
wall and show some progress on this
front he will hurt his standing with his
base he could be right about that I
think the argument for him doing
something now versus next year is that I
think he has the stronger hand right now
as you mentioned earlier in the show
that five billion dollars that was
approved earlier this month that goes
kaput in January and when Nancy Pelosi
writes a new spending bill with her
caucus it will almost certainly contain
less than five billion dollars for a
wall you know Amy this hunt for this
illegal immigrant who shot and killed a
police officer the sheriff's office out
there talking about the officer who was
killed take a listen Randy Richards yes
he was a police officer but what needs
to be known is that he was truly just a
human being and an American patriot ron
was not born in America Ron was born in
Fiji he came to this country with one
purpose and that was to serve this
country thirty three old Ron Singh
killed in that shooting you know we've
seen these incidents before Amy the Kate
Steinle case in California that affected
the broader picture on border security
in one way or another because is this
one of those moments well it's a really
horrible and tragic story and you're
right bread to note that we have had a
lot of stories like this we've had a lot
of discussion about the wall we've had
the caravan we've had an election we've
had políticas ation of the wall
throughout the last two years and when
you look though at opinions of the wall
they literally have not changed since
the since the 2016 campaign I went back
and I looked the Quinnipiac poll in
November of 2016 support for the wall
42% opposition 55% two years later now
we're in
December of 2018 support for the wall
43% and 54% disagree so with the idea of
a wall so the reality is that we have
over these last two years no mind we've
not seen any minds changed on the
opinion of the wall despite all the
other things that are going on around it
and instead what we're getting is
instead of broad or broadening of
coalition's for either side they're just
hardening and deepening moyen and you're
seeing that in this this shutdown of the
government both sides seem to think that
they have the upper hand I think that
Democrats really believe that denying
Trump a victory on border wall funding
is absolutely key they know that this
was something he campaigned on they know
that this is something that does have a
lot of support 40-plus percent of the
American people wanting a wall is
something that has that has a huge
backing for it and even more than a wall
there are greater concerns about border
security which i think is a much more
compromised position that the people on
both left and right care deeply about
but at the same time Trump thinks he's
I've got a strong hand because 75% of
the government is funded he thinks that
it shows that he cares about this issue
that he's willing to get credit for
shutting down the government by that he
cares so much that he's willing to go to
that to that extent and so there is this
intractability in this fight I do think
that while the wall itself might be with
the numbers that Amy's talking about
concern about border security is a
long-standing concern that goes back
decades and that there's a lot of
frustration that the government has done
so little to ensure the security of our
borders you know we saw Peter Doocy up
on Capitol Hill basically the only
person up on Capitol Hill Jason it
seemed like there were tumbleweeds going
down the halls and they'll be out until
Monday meantime the blame game continues
Republicans and Democrats ticketless
the needle has moved towards a very long
shutdown
just because of the impasse that we're
seeing in the the unwillingness of
Democrats to actually engage in
meaningful dialogue nobody likes the
stress of the uncertainty public
servants why I go to work they don't
want to be
and they certainly don't want to think
this could go on for weeks it is a great
shame to this administration and to the
outgoing Republican Congress that we've
arrived at this kind of point just the
past minute Jason the president tweeting
out this isn't about the wall everybody
knows that a wall will work perfectly in
Israel the wall works 99.9% this is only
about the Dems not letting Donald Trump
and the Republicans have win they may
have the 10 Senate votes but we have the
issue border security 2020 that was
about a few minutes ago Jason yeah I
think the president is right that this
is about the resistance not wanting to
give him any quarter on any issue
including
this issue but I think that in in in the
larger sense the public is with the
president in the term in the sense of
caring about border security much more
than Democrats seem to care about border
security we see this not only in their
opposition to physical barriers we see
this in their attacks on ice' abolish
border enforcement of any kind their
support for sanctuary cities and so
forth they just are not they don't look
serious about border security of any
kind we're just talking about a wall why
didn't that work for the midterms why
didn't it work in the districts that
were suburbs outside of big cities why
didn't the issue work because obviously
the president was hitting it hard in the
lead-up to the midterms well I think
there were other concerns that that
people had in the mind and and I think
that you know the public did increase
the Republican majority in the Senate
while it turned control of the house
over to two Democrats but I don't know
that I think Trump felt as if he didn't
harp on this the losses would have been
even greater than they were now that's
difficult to prove but I think that
badest is thinking on this issue but his
base is with him on this Brett in the
short run I really don't see him feeling
a lot of pain on this in the long run
perhaps if this goes on and on and
then perhaps maybe you'll see some
negative negative response to trump on
this issue but but not right now I don't
think it's been going on long enough and
we're so far away from 2020 that I don't
think it's gonna have an impact on that
either
short answer Amy then Molly do we get a
deal in the next days after Monday we're
not gonna get a deal until the new
Congress is in place and even then we're
going to have a debate for a little
while longer but at some point there are
no winners in this there are only losers
it's just a question of who looks less
bad I actually think there is room for a
win here in that Democrats can bring
back daca and and talk about resolving
that issue without having the courts
settle everything and you can get border
security and it seems like would be a
great time for people to get a little
bit of what they want on both sides we
shall see